now the latest on the coronavirus and
the dramatic jump in cases led by a
whirring number of children
now getting sick michigan is under more
covert stress right now than any other
state in the country take a look at
these numbers the daily cases
tell the story they're now rising to
levels nearly as high as the latest big
surge
that was around the holidays michigan
governor gretchen whitmer told faisal
nation yesterday
she's frustrated that the biden
administration will not send a larger
share of vaccine doses
to her state we know we've got even
greater
capacity we could get more vaccines in
arms and
when there is a surge we think that it's
important that
we we go to we rush in to meet where
that need is because
what's happening in michigan today could
be what's happening in other states
tomorrow
president biden says michigan will get
more help to carry out testing and
vaccinations
joining us now is dr ashish jaw he's the
dean of brown university school of
public health
good morning to you dr john always good
to see you
good morning thanks for having me on
gail so we're going to start with this
let's start in michigan of course where
right now people are very concerned
about the number of children so i want
to get your reaction to that
in particular and what you think needs
to be done about it
yeah so the cons the situation in
michigan is pretty concerning
obviously they're seeing a lot of
infections it's it's as bad as it was
over the holidays
the variants are definitely one of the
drivers of it and what we need to do
right now is a combination of
people in michigan need to try to stay
home as much as possible for the next
few weeks
and from a policy point of view we
absolutely should be surging both
testing and vaccinations to michigan you
know many states are sort of not even
using up their supplies anymore instead
of sending
more vaccines there we should now be
sending more and more vaccines to
michigan
and other hot spots but is michigan do
you think dr john an indication of
things to come for other states
you know i'm hoping not i think part of
the reason michigan got into trouble is
actually in the fall and winter
they did better than many other states
so they have a lot more vulnerable
people
who have not been infected it's
unfortunately one of the downsides of
having done a better job
i'm hoping that other states as long as
people keep vaccinating are going to be
able to avoid what michigan is going
through
now let's let's turn to that j j vaccine
because george is now the third state to
temporarily shut down
sites for giving the j and j vaccine and
all the experts say don't worry about it
everything is still okay at what point
should we get concerned because this
seems very concerning about the j
j vaccine yeah gail look
we've got to watch the data and we
should be concerned when the data says
that we should be concerned
right now when we're vaccinating
millions of people
the reactions we've seen have been very
mild
light-headedness some people have felt
nauseated and that has happened in a
tiny tiny portion
of people so my take is follow the data
and once it looks concerning
or if it ever looks concerning then
obviously act
so far i haven't seen anything that
concerns me i'd still feel very
comfortable
recommending j j for my family you would
okay
have you gotten your vaccine i have
okay which one did you get do you mind
saying
no i don't mind at all and i didn't have
any choice i i got it at my hospital i
got the moderna and i got i found out
what i was getting when i landed when i
got there and they just they said this
is what you're getting this morning i
know that's what happened to me too i
would take whatever they had given me
but let's talk about people have been
vaccinated a lot of us have
and so how much protection do we have
with the vaccine how long do you think
it's going to last
and does it protect people against the
variants
yeah so these vaccines are really
remarkable i i think they're going to
last uh so
so far the evidence is going to last at
least six months but i think that's a
floor not a ceiling
meaning i think these vaccines can last
at least a year probably longer
they seem to hold up very well against
all the variants
against the uk variant that's spreading
widely it's it's terrific
even against some of the more tricky
variants it seems to be largely holding
up all right dr ashish
always good to have you to talk about
this we thank you